like i'm just saying technically i could
just screenshot the entity right
like
there you go i own it now
is this your thing
sorry your bad b your wifey
is this your girlfam
my fiance
okay she belongs to me now yo
okay fine but you have to admit a lot of
these projects are pretty bad like this
one
what is this
it's a rock utility it's a rock trait
it's a rock about the team
we like the rock road map
oh wait we'll be developing a
state-of-the-art metaverse mmo with play
to earn mechanics and your rock
represents your access to the dao and
the governance of the platform see white
paper here
oh never mind
yeah i think that's pretty much it on
their website there's no utility it's
literally just a rock i mean it doesn't
even look that good
man this is completely useless i mean
it's obvious that no effort was put into
this right
right
sorry what
oh i just bought 20 of them are you
serious i like the rock
kids buying rocking the t's for forty
thousand logan paul i like the world
i'll be honest none of this interesting
stuff made sense until i saw the vlog
[Music]
[Music]
holy [ __ ] look at the price
how the hell did you know
[Applause]
like the rock
oh [ __ ]
should i buy it
i mean there's no intrinsic valley but
that's not what we're trading on
[Music]
i mean it wouldn't be the first time i
bought a useless rock
all right [ __ ] it
[ __ ] there's a left-facing rock
[Music]
all right i bought it
damn i got a pretty cheap one too 56 eth
apart from this guy
wait
[Music]
oh yeah i don't like the rocks anymore
i like this now
[Music]